hey wassup guys my name is a Chennai
welcome to another episode of game
programming episode hundred and six
let's go ahead and talk about debugging
displays and all that stuff because
there's a lot of really cool things that
we can do with that and I'm gonna show
you one thing that we can do with that
here okay so I've got the sprite class
open here as you can probably tell them
that's because uhm I want to kind of
touch on this because we've kind of done
let's just say half it's not really
anywhere close but let's just say we've
done half of of this debugging method
already and I want to just point that
out so that you guys don't get too
confused we've got a way over here to
create a sprite that is simply a size
and a color right and then obviously
that's to create a square one and this
is to create one that isn't square you
can obviously use it to create a square
method rather a square sprite but um
it's got a width and height it's got
several parameters and this basically
just allows us to create a sprite with
uh with these details right okay and the
reason that that's actually useful to us
is because we can kind of render it
anywhere and as we do go ahead and
render that you'll see that in our
screen class which is over here in the
graphics place right over here in our
screen class we have render sprite and
we have this option this boolean fixed
okay and if something is fixed that
means it is actually tied to the level
which means that it's coordinates as
position it's location is relative to
the level not to the screen not to the
monitor not to the window the actual
Windows seven window in this case it's
not relative to that fixed means it's
actually relative to the level which
means it will move with the player kind
of like as in it'll move yeah it'll move
with the plot like it'll it'll move
according to other players now that's
great okay and that's one way to do it
but sometimes we just want to quickly
throw something up there that isn't
necessarily sprite right this stuff is
man this method ran a sprite in this
this method this are constructed to make
a sprite this way is meant for actual
game elements not debugging elements and
the reason is we obviously need a new
sprite object and the word sprite you
can tell isn't really supposed to be
used with debugging in fact sprite is
probably something we would debug so I
want to talk to you guys a bit about
that today but what I want to show you
guys right now is how sprite kind of
works okay
so if I go ahead and go into um I just
want to go to swollen level really
quickly and see what our coordinates
roughly are our tiles are sixteen by
sixteen I believe I always forget this
yeah well says tile size sixteen so I'm
just gonna assume that's accurate but
the idea is that um okay so our dummy is
it like maybe fifteen fifty three okay
that's cool so I'm gonna go ahead and go
into the the shooter class here and in
the shooter class on the render what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go ahead and say
new sprite I'm gonna create a sprite
that's 80 by 80 and it's gonna be what
around the color okay let's just make it
red okay red okay
I'm gonna create a new sprite here I'm
gonna render it straightaway or rather
the way that we would render it of
course is by calling screen render
sprite the in the x and y position so
we'll make the X&Y will will make this
let's go ahead and just for now make it
80 by 80 as well and then the sprite of
course will be here and fixed will be
false okay so it'll kind of float if I
can have any type to that there yeah
Floyd okay let's go ahead and make sure
this is outside of the constructor of
course another bracket in that should be
good alright let's go ahead and see what
that looks like so what we should see is
this massive red rectangle and you can
see it kind of follows it moves with the
player is in like it doesn't it you know
it doesn't move relative to other player
is its relative to the screen okay
and it's actually rendering on the
projectiles and stuff but over the mobs
so that's interesting as well but that's
kind of what we're gonna do here if we
do set it equal to true of causing and
you guys notice I'm just kind of
reiterating what what what we all
already know just so you guys can get it
a bit cleaner and obviously it's been a
while since we've done that but um let's
go ahead and change this to maybe I
think it's like 53 times 16 by oh that's
that's probably the why isn't it I'm
worried about his phone level yeah so 53
is the why and then like 17
if the X fixed it's true so what we
should say here is I moved down here we
can say that now we now have this red
thing that stays there yeah
it stays there it's it's its it stays
with the level okay
so we're coming gonna do something like
that but it's gonna be made with a
debugging kind of point of view and for
the debugging
I guess use write this screen to render
spry method and we create a new sprite
object here this stuff is meant for
actual game elements now let's talk
about making a kind of debugging element
okay so under util okay I'm gonna put it
into you tell I'm gonna go new class and
I'm gonna call it very very simply debug
okay that's it deep big come on
debug debug there we go and right now
this is gonna be a static class all
right so it's not gonna have any in fact
let's just make sure we enforce the fact
that is static by making um the
constructor private but yeah this is
gonna be a static class okay so none
this is never supposed to be
instantiated ever public static void
draw rect okay
that stands for draw rectangle I'm sorry
about that noise outside by the way
here's some on the camera way it's
something I draw rect okay and all
that's draw all that we really need for
draw rect has obviously we need a way to
draw it so we definitely need a an
instance of the screen class yeah and
then we also need the X and y position
so in x and y as well as the width and
the height and that's and we probably
need whether it's fixed or not all right
great okay so what we've done here is
we've kind of given ourselves I don't
know if I want to put the screen is the
first parameter yeah we'll go ahead do
that we'll leave it like that
make sure you import screen of course
and this does not all fit but basically
here we go we have six lovely parameters
here we're gonna go ahead and call a
method in screen call screen dot draw
rect
okay that'll obviously that'll just
roughly that'll probably take X Y width
height and fixed so everything set for
screen I'm say doesn't need a sake
screen because it is screen so we'll
create that method in the screen class
so you can see here in the screen class
I'm going to
we're gonna make this method called draw
rect and now what we're gonna do here is
um is actually make sure that we draw a
rectangle now this isn't like a fill
rectangle thing so it won't be filled
and that's that's the point actually
someone to show you guys a quick
algorithm that will very very very
easily
it stretches XP and YP very very easily
draw a rectangle so what is a rectangle
a rectangle is made up of four lines if
I go into paint out now I'm shorter Nia
really explain this to you guys but um
just in case give you a better
understanding rectangles for lines so
what we need to do is we need to wait a
starting point and we need to draw a
line just like that okay we also need to
do the same for y okay that's out that's
the first two steps of drawing a
rectangle so the less that's our goal
right now just to draw those two lines
okay Oh a color would also be nice I
forgot completely about color so let's
go ahead and width height and we'll
probably put color in here I'm gonna
spell it I'm just gonna call put it
right after height here we can obviously
make uhm other other methods here that
will um rappers basically that so that
we don't need to use all these
parameters but some in color okay great
so um okay so that's the first thing we
do so let's go ahead and type in for int
y equals this Y position here because we
want it to start at the Y position of
course and go on till height so if y
four will I guess for y is less than um
why people are site we will force
increment Y here we'll do the same for X
but make sure it's outside that's
another thing you have to realize okay
they're not nested they're not inside
like that okay this is not a nested for
loop if we were filling a rectangle yeah
it would be but some here it's not make
sure that we use X here of course XP in
fact we want as well do X first because
they're not nested and it's not right
again with this with the whole deal with
doing y first when it's nested that's
really just a convention
because when you're scanning when you're
drawing scan lines you're usually
drawing them down why so you're drawing
them horizontally not vertically that's
just a bit of a convention here it
doesn't matter because we're not feeling
anything in so I'm gonna go ahead and
just shift X up here you can keep it
however you like great so that looks
pretty good to me okay now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say pixels X
unless yeah so this is I think okay yeah
this is the X 1 so we'll actually go
ahead and say we'll go ahead and say X
los I think it'll just be okay so we
actually have to do XP plus X plus y P
times width and that'll actually be a
Vista width and we'll set that equal to
the color okay great and that's our X
figured out
sorry I just kind of figured this out on
the fly Y will be sorry the same here
except will actually use XP instead
which I which by the way refers to the
position right not alpha lope and then
we'll change this to be y plus y plus y
T all right
great now this thing has to be enclosed
in brackets because otherwise we're
evaluating Y P times width and then
adding Y on we want to evaluate that and
then apply it yeah that looks pretty
good to me and it's not worth of course
days for both of them because that is
the width of the array so let's go ahead
and try this out okay we've got a basic
method here it sets it equal to a color
um now what doesn't do okay it just
obviously just draws the two okay and
this is fastly and like it's not
finished yet but let's go ahead and
nevertheless see what it looks like I'm
just gonna close all these out the
closet that we don't need at all just so
we're dealing with what we need and over
here I'm simply gonna call debug
began with the DB DVR don't draw a
rectangle so screen XA and wire will
just put maybe like again 8080 maybe not
maybe that's a lot like 40 40 will make
the the width here we'll set that equal
to maybe a hundred will make the height
like 40 will make the color pink and
fixed will be false where I matter yet
okay so let's go ahead and launch that
and see what happens okay so we kind of
get we get an interesting little thing
going on here they don't seem to start
at quite the right spot but it is
generally what we're looking for
let's go back to the screen method a
screen class real quick and see what's
up okay so obviously we're actually
already calculating the offset here so
I'm not sure why I did that but this
just needs to be X but this does need a
would be YP alright and it's gonna be
the same thing here so this does not
need a YP rather just a Y because Y is
actually equal to YP so I kind of messed
that up for some reason I thought we
were going from zero to width like that
and you could do it that way as well
right and then just calculate the offset
because that's how we do it every other
time but here it's just we might as well
start the for loop at are the correct
position here I guess there's two ways
of doing that if we launch that now we
should see it perfectly done okay sweet
so that is what we're dealing with right
here now the other thing that you need
to realize is that that's half a
rectangle right we need to draw these
two okay so how do we do that well
luckily it's really easy and it doesn't
really require much okay all we have to
do is draw the exact same thing again
but offset it so this is the x1 which
means that it's the horizontal one that
we're looking at we need to simply
render it again add plus height okay so
let's just render that see what that
looks like okay great so we've got this
side now and then the final side is
gonna be the same here right so we're
simply going to actually add width and
we don't really need brackets around
this but
we'll do that anyway just so it looks
nicer and then you can see we've got an
entire rectangle this is awesome great
so there's something up there's actually
two little problems the first one okay
is the fact that and you guys won't
actually see this right now because this
isn't fixable but we're not handling any
kind of clipping okay so if I were to
for example make the rectangle be
outside the screen so intruder if I make
that like negative 40 then it's just
gonna crash again he's gonna launch four
okay even better it's not gonna crash
it's gonna do this ridiculous thing
where it warps the screen okay not good
okay and the same thing applies if we
make the width too large here okay it's
you look okay it's just it's not really
working out okay and we need to figure
that out okay we need a bit we're
basically in to tell her that if you're
outside the boundaries don't render okay
because if it does it will um in this
case it'll warp it but sometimes because
we're her name is me better but in other
cases it will simply crash with an array
index out of bounds exception okay
really important stuff so to fix that
we've done it before basically I'm just
gonna rush through this because it
doesn't shouldn't take that long but if
X P is greater than or equal to their
stop with make sure you don't use width
because weather would be the width of
the rectangle whereas by this dot with
we're referring to the width of the
actual screen because this of course
means implies that it's referring to a
field rather than simply a local
variable or a parameter in this case
we'll also make sure that Y now not Y
page is why actually this should be down
here obviously Y being this Y here is
less than zero okay or Y is better than
equal to this dot height and will
continue which means that we'll skip
that into that iteration of the for loop
and we just basically won't ever render
this same thing needs to happen for X
I'll just repeat this one step at a time
for each of the things all that needs to
happen here is because it's the first
one cut
we just need to basically replicate this
but for X so X is less than zero
right or X is greater than or equal to
this dot width all right or Y and y pay
actually is greater than equal to this
top high now you guys might be like what
about why pay less than zero and don't
forget that we're actually doing this
kind of like twice right because we're
rendering these two different things so
if we handle everything up here what's
actually gonna happen is you know this
pixels this one might be the ones
causing the problem so this one might be
the one that's actually out of like the
top the top part of the of the rectangle
right this top part here it could be off
the screen yeah if we move this up here
for example then you guys will see what
I mean this might be off the screen but
the bottom parts still fine so we still
want to render the bottom part which
don't want to enter the top part but if
we go ahead and handle it at once then
both the top and the bottom will
actually disappear okay so that's why we
split this up and we say simply that if
Y is greater than 0 then we render so
what we're saying here is we're saying
that if and by that I mean keep freaking
okay this should be X so no that's still
wrong
hang on what am i doing so if think
think think if Y pay okay my bad if Y
pay is is greater than 0 then we render
it ok so what we're saying is that if Y
pays less than 0 do not render this but
still render this okay and that's what's
kind of gonna make us work here we're
gonna copy basically just comes with the
same thing for here we're simply gonna
say that if X P here is greater than 0
then render that ok yeah so let's go
ahead and render that and at the moment
we get everything is good but in deep in
a shooter let's go ahead and adjust
these indexes the bits will set this
again to negative 40 and what you guys
should see here is the fact that it's
simply it's not warping or anything it's
just not rendering anything past that
okay now there's actually another
problem going on
the lot it's part to see but um you know
what I know I'm gonna forget to zoom in
in while I'm editing this so what I'm
gonna do here is this isn't really gonna
work out like I wanted it to but I'm
using magnifier here okay there we go
you guys might be able to see that
there's a there's actually a it's not
rendering that last pixel there okay and
that's got a really easy solution okay
all we need to do is simply say that for
either I guess X or Y it doesn't really
matter we will do it for y we'll set it
to less than or equal to so basically
we're just saying draw one last pixel in
there and if I move this back into the
screen you guys will where are we you
guys will be able to see that it works
really well and that covers that now if
you were being really picky you might be
able you might say that aw well then
it's having is rendering two pixels and
it is but you know let's just be quiet
about that because our other option
would be to manually render it here so
we could go ahead and say you know like
pixels xp+ with plus y p+ we're up its
height times this stuff width equals
color and do it outside of the four lips
because it's just one pixel but um that
would be just you know let's just not
let's just not do that okay okay good so
this is taking a while it usually does
these episodes of game programming but
I'm just trying to explain everything as
good as I can well it's my formal method
here we'll make it um public static void
I've been drawn rec again but instead
this time we'll just go ahead and omit
the color and so let's go here get rid
of color and then we'll simply say we'll
simply call the draw rect method here
with everything except for color
we'll add probably read it make bread
plate to default color okay and that'll
just basically I'm gonna make sure
that'll basically just allow us to if we
go into shooter they'll just allow us to
draw a rectangle without specifying the
color and then if we do that it will
just make it red which it has done great
okay so one more thing when you talk
about is worth whether it's fixed or not
because if it's not fixed yeah okay it's
it's obviously that that does absolutely
nothing right now so let's go ahead and
change the coordinates quickly b-17
times sixteen by nothing like
fifty-seven alone times sixteen and
we'll go into screen okay and in draw
rectangle will simply add the same
clipping if I'll just copy and paste is
just to emphasize it this affixed from
Ronis bright right so this offsetting
for the XP and YP we will simply paste
that in here okay and that is it
okay that is if the fixed balloon is
true which it is in this case because as
you can see we've specified a true here
okay
we'll launch that let's go down here and
arraigned X out of bounds exception fun
okay so we actually forgot to handle the
other side of this thing when the handle
like the top and the left basically so
what we need to do also is fill out
quickly here if Y P this time right plus
hi so before we did the other thing but
here we're gonna do if Y P plus hi is
greater than equal this type so what
we've done before what we've done before
and what does hit up continue let's just
terminated suffocation
well we what we kind of did before here
is we said if Y P is greater than equal
to this high right then continue but
here we're saying if Y P plus hide and
the reason we're doing this is because
if Y P is actually greater than hi
basically greater than or equal to
height then the entire rectangle would
be you know would not need to be rented
or at least those two well yeah I guess
we'll at least those two the top and
bottom parts of the rectangle would not
what would not need to be rented but
some we still might want to render
you know the bottom part so basically
what I'm saying is we we couldn't put
hide up here because we still do want to
render this okay because that's the top
part of the rectangle and then we met we
run a check for the bottom part of the
rectangle to see if we can render that
okay because otherwise if we put them
both up there what you'll see is both
the top and bottom won't render but we
want you know we kind of want one we
want one of them to render because
sometimes of course you have this
situation where only the top is out of
bounds
not at the bottom so we still want to be
able to render the bottom which is why
we can't just simply continue because
that would skip both pixel rendering
pieces of code so I'll change that is to
X P plus width this door width and now
when we're on up we should not get any
kind of rain decks out of bounds
exception if we just go all the way down
here you can see that we've got this red
rectangle here and it looks pretty good
I mean it doesn't like it as you can say
clipping works pretty well here just as
I say that crashes and the reason that
crashed of course is because X P here is
equal to negative 81 it is over here as
well but here you can see that we
actually only render that FX P is
greater than zero so it's not you know
let's bring it back here make sure that
we don't render that part now it's a bit
different over here you can see that
here it's Y P naught X P okay so they're
numb if we save this really quickly I'll
just quickly just make sure that that
does work and if it does which is of
course should at this point if I just go
down here okay there we go that looks
pretty good
now you can see what I was talking about
with the clipping there if I go out like
that
if I just if that thing is not in bounds
that disappears okay and that's why I
want you guys to know that the solution
isn't as simple as X P is greater than
zero okay it actually needs to be X P
plus width
okay greater than zero same thing over
here two plus high okay and then if I go
ahead and I save this and go back to I
should see that it does actually render
so that's what I wanted to just visually
show you guys what the difference would
be because you can't get away with just
saying you know one if statement with
that's not gonna work in this case
because we're actually rendering two
different arrays of pixels okay we're
rendering one for the one fer basically
on each axis one for each I guess edge
right top and bottom and left and right
okay anyway that's gonna wrap up this
episode I hope you guys did enjoy it
the reason I actually did this entire
thing was because we're gonna probably
talk about more boundaries and making
sure the mobs actually stay within their
boundaries next episode and the reason
that's really important of course is we
don't want more of us in our game to
wander off anyway so in other words if I
put a mob at this particular paddock but
I don't want it to be able to get out
and you know putting just a collision
meshes and not good enough we want to
kind of just contain any within a box
and it's gonna be pretty hard to
visually see that box which is why with
tools such as this debug class now and
this episode took probably longer than
it should a lot longer than it should
but um
I just wanted to make sure I was
thinning my point across ah
and the point once again is the fact
that um this kind of stuff will ensure
that we can visually represent certain
things like certain boundaries onto our
screen okay and we'll probably add more
debug tools as we go along but that's it
I hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
game programming if you did please hit
the like button and don't forget that of
course if you guys want to have a
private tutorial with me then you can
certainly book one over here on my
website the channel icon for slash
tutoring the link is in the description
simply pick an available time fill in
the form with that available time nor
that it is in Australian is in standard
time because I do live in Melbourne
Australia and then all you have to do is
fill this out submit it and I will get
back to you very very shortly so thank
you guys a lot for watching and I'll see
you next time goodbye
you